foreign
I would love that uh never using my
money to give away stuff is my favorite
thing I think it's my spiritual gift at
this point to give away your money Dave
and uh everybody's got to have a calling
and it can't happen for me because I
work here I think that's only fair but
for you all listening out there we've
got a chance for you to win some of
Dave's money in the Ramsay cash giveaway
all month long you can enter to win up
to 500 bucks or the 3 000 grand prize
all you gotta do is go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway and yes
real people actually win this stuff
which is really cool make sure to enter
every single day to increase your chance
to win there's no purchase necessary but
sorry kids you do have to be 18 or older
to win and today just keeps getting
better because the ten dollar sale is
back and you all know I love a good deal
and this is about uh as good of a deal
as you're gonna get on all of the
products that you need to start Building
Wealth a career you love Improvement
almost all of our best-selling books are
ten dollars that's impressive that's
like when we get some new ones on there
this year yeah Dr John delones is on
there own your past change your future
uh baby steps millionaires is on there
that's Dave's latest book that lays out
stories of real people including
teachers who became millionaires is
using the baby steps and I did some math
Dave because I was curious what three
thousand dollars can get you in today's
world so the grand prize is three
thousand dollars no purchase necessary
and what can three thousand dollars get
you well it can get you 85 days of Doggy
Daycare if you're me which is pretty
impressive
you're kidding yeah is that a lot to you
or a little I don't know what is Doggy
Daycare it's where you send your dog to
be taken care of while you're at work
I can't just wait on you to get home
well you want to give it a good life
Dave you know you send your kids to
daycare why not the dog
oh Lord what is this world coming to you
tell me okay uh it can get you less than
a tenth of a Bitcoin if you're
interested in that
yeah
okay yeah it could get you get this 300
copies of the total money making now I'm
in okay imagine that all right if you
win this giveaway and you turn around
and buy 300 copies of The Total Money
Makeover change 300 people's lives with
a coaster for their that's pretty coffee
table here's what else could get you
maybe and I mean maybe two Taylor Swift
tickets yeah one ending on the day I
don't know who the half gone is but you
get one and a half for that yeah
goodness gracious and lastly this is my
favorite it can actually buy you a
beater car in 2023 and James our
producer did the research because I know
the haters are coming after us already
here's what this can get you in the
Nashville area at 2002 Honda with 117
000 miles on it
for three grand that's a Jesus car is it
yeah you said they're all in one Accord
there you go he's been here all week
three thousand bucks you missed your
calling and stand up Dave I did but
instead he's giving away sitting down
there you go I love it don't miss it
ramseysolutions.com slash giveaway I
told you three thousand bucks it's
impressive and all you gotta do is just
come register
that's it come hang out with us
ramseysolutions.com